Цікава місія бути гідом.
[сміється]
Це я маю вас за дві години...
Щоб ви полюбили моє рідне місто.
Це Славутич, крихітко.
Славутич будували 8 республік
колишнього Радянського Союзу.
А сьогодні це незалежні країни.
І ми можем одночасно бути в Славутичі і бути у 8 країнах.
15 хвилин у Вірменії, 20 хвилин у Грузії і так далі.
Тому в момент, коли ніхто нікуди не подорожує,
всі славутичани подорожують.
Рішення про будівництво
міста Славутича ухвалили,
після того як сталася аварія
на Чорнобильській атомній електростанції.
Місто, де б зібралися всі ті,
хто жив колись у Прип’яті на момент аварії.
І для тих нових людей, які тоді
прийняли цей виклик — рятувати світ.
І от вирішили побудувати нове місто.
За два роки побудували Славутич.
[сміється]
Єреванський квартал, Бакінський
квартал, Тбіліський квартал..
Далі в нас є Московський,
Ленінградський, Бєлградський.
Країни Балтії: це Вільнюський,
Рижський і Талінський.
І найбільший, найбільш потужний,
найбільша забудова,
найбільше будинків, найбільше
котеджної забудови — це Київський.
Наш рідний Київський квартал.
Україна найбільше постаралася
і зробила найбільший внесок.
Класна така погода.
[сміється]
В суботу така спека була, таке сонце!
Така супер погода була!
Я також водила людей, робила екскурсію.
З різних куточків приїжджали люди,
з Білорусі приїхали до нас.
ІТ-шники дивилися.
В цій групі вони були і дуже серйозно запитували,
щодо можливість зупинитися,
після всіх цих подій в Білорусі,
на роботу й на життя в Славутичі.
Ми прийшли з вами до Вільнюської котеджної забудови.
І на що би я хотіла увагу тут
вашу звернути — це паркани.
Подивіться, за проєктом, їх взагалі не було.
Але просто люди вже з часом...
По-перше, там якісь є тренди,
мода якась, на паркани.
А по-друге, як людина себе комфортно почуває?
Треба їй цю загорожу чи не треба?
От за мною будинок, де господарям не потрібно
ні від кого відгороджуватися.
Вони зберігають, до речі, цю концепцію.
Повторюся, за першим планом парканів не було.
Тобто якщо ми зараз поїдемо
кудись в Європу подорожувати,
ми на це звертаємо увагу: вікна відкриті,
немає нічого закритого, немає парканів.
І це вже така традиція більше наша, українська,
закриватися, зробити високі паркани.
Але ви бачите, наскільки по-різному
люди можуть це робити.
Це різні підходи, у всіх свої.
Олександр довгий час працював на ЧАЕС.
Він працював на об’єкті укриття.
Був дозиметристом і
він був фотографом-дозиметристом.
І в нього також така династія.
Його батько був директором об’єкту укриття.
І він просто цікавиться оцією темою Чорнобиля.
В нього канал свій, який він веде
і присвячує темі Чорнобиля.
[російською] Уже восени було вирішено...
[російською] Тобто прийшло розуміння, так би мовити,
того, що в Прип'ять ніхто не повернеться.
[російською] Хоча ще влітку, це мені батько
розповідав, коли він літав на ЦК КПРС,
[російською] він летів у літаку із секретарем
обласного комітету Запорізької області.
[російською] І той йому, нібито, сказав, що є команда,
[російською] щоб 1 вересня, в Прип'яті школярі пішли до школи.
[сміється]
[російською] На що батько відповів: «Це нонсенс».
[російською] Тобто у партійних функціонерів
Союзу, ще літом,
[російською] були надії, я так розумію,
повернути Прип'ять, реанімувати її.
Місто будувалося ще в 1987-1988 роках.
І це ще Радянський Союз.
Але ми, і всі туристи, і ми — славутичани,
завжди звертаємо на це увагу:
немає в місті радянських символів.
Це було зроблено спеціально.
Якщо ми звернемо увагу, то всі пам’ятники
або скульптури в нас оголені.
Так група цих дослідників, проєктувальників,
показали зв’язок людини з природою.
Що людина, в такому своєму первозданному
вигляді, зараз тут, в місті, перебуває.
Тут їй комфортно.
Місто серед лісу, ліс в місті, місто в лісі.
Ми зараз з вами в Тбіліському кварталі
нашого міста, міста Славутича.
Вгорі ми бачимо таке нагадування нам про те,
що це архітектура дуже давня, древня.
І вона навіть дає нам відсилку
таку до замкової архітектури.
Ми бачимо таке прикрашання.
Що всередині?
Тут є шашличні, шашличні кімнати.
Якщо ми будемо...
Це не жарт, це так називають їх містяни, так.
Це кімната для виготовлення шашликів,
для смаження шашликів.
Ми прийшли всередину Єреванського кварталу.
І тут зразу відчуваємо гостинність цих людей.
Тут є мангальні такі осередки.
Їх два.
Два діють всередині кварталу і є такі зони мангальні.
І дуже часто запитують, чи ними користуються.
Так, ними користуються.
Ними користуються не тільки мешканці цього кварталу,
але й приходять і влаштовують вечірки
з усіх кварталів, якщо хочуть.
Приносять все, що треба для такого
барбекю, для такої вечірки.
Або для якогось святкування.
І ось тут відбувається таке класне спілкування.
Зараз місто, населення наше,
мешканці, всі дуже-дуже схвильовані.
А що ж далі?
Але, крім хвилювання, вони нічого більше не роблять.
Вони просто чекають, що знову відкриється завод,
відкриється нова там якась...
Що для них щось зробить держава
і хтось для них щось зробить.
Але це не так.
Вже час уже пішов уперед,
вже ніхто не зробить щось за тебе.
Ти маєш зробити щось для себе,
для своєї родини, для свого міста.
Слоган міста: «Місто нових ідей».
Ми зробили ребрендинг.
І зараз ми жартуємо.
І треба щоб було місто нових ідей,
місто нових людей і місто нових подій.
[сміється]
Тобто завдяки подіям ми хочемо, щоб приїхали
до нас нові мешканці, нові люди, нові ідеї.
Люди, які будуть робити нові проєкти.
Сумуємо за молоддю, яка від’їжджає з міста.
Але щоб не тільки молоді, ясно,
що молоді нам потрібні...
Але, можливо, якісь люди,
які просто більше люблять уповільнення,
повільне життя в спокійному місті,
просто до нас приїхали.